Michael B Jordan reacts to Marvel Comics
legend Stan Lee's death are broken
honestly the man behind comic book
creations like The Avengers Fantastic
Four and Black Panther died on Monday
and et caught up with Michael who
starred in Marvel's Black Panther at a
surprise screening of his new film Creed
2 in his hometown of Newark New Jersey
later that day you're thought to
understand Lee
it's a heartbroken honestly 95 years old
he lived a full life made an impact of
so many different people literally
changed the face of entertainment and so
many different ways you show people how
to dream how to escape you know the
problems that you know that they have
their current situations so creative so
fun it's so incredible that I feel
honored to be a part of you know one of
the last films he had a chance to be a
part of you know and for him to see
coming to fruition like panther that he
created image I could create it back in
the day so for him to kind of see that
coming come full circle I think was was
awesome and I was something I'll cherish
with me for the rest of my life so you
know rest and please Stanley and we lost
really really going you know what I
think I'll just take these bring them
over here and hold on for safekeeping
you